it's Monday [ __ ] mad flavor here
it's been a couple of days but I'm back
[ __ ]
my back feels better my attitude is
adjusted I'm home for 10 days and it's
all over but the [ __ ] shouting
you understand me always remember the
people that tell your note today the
same [ __ ] they're gonna suck
your dick tomorrow you know how I know
cuz I'm living it [ __ ] these
people got no [ __ ] shame they got
nothing so it don't really matter go out
there and do the best you could do and
beside that [ __ ] [ __ ] Minnie [ __ ]
them in the other here cuz it don't
matter at the end of the week if you're
doing the work they can't [ __ ] stop
it
got two different reef is today one
better than the [ __ ] another one
understand I got a little sour OG from
perennial and I got a little [ __ ] oh
this [ __ ] it says it's a [ __ ] hinder
cadet but it's got some sativa and it
[ __ ] your head up and I'm saying I wish
turned up my roller skater
[ __ ] him sixth grade yesterday after I
slope that that's worse than hearing
Japanese people yell sometimes you know
sit down Nelly New York City was a lot
of [ __ ] fun chemist M you guys have
bad [ __ ] you're gonna get shot
in New York City though there's some
[ __ ] evil people walking around they
creepy eyeballs in his [ __ ] so always
have your [ __ ] gun up in NYC and I'm
saying [ __ ] all that [ __ ] around and
pokemons and I'm looking around New York
City's real jacket and your [ __ ] face
they should call New York City a reality
show when is this [ __ ] neighborhood
gonna blow up cuz it's [ __ ] real jack
listen I'm back in LA with these
gluten-free [ __ ] and now I let
you go home you look at your
neighborhood you walk around your school
your heart then it's over jack I got
three weeks till I shoot this special
I'm gonna come out the box like [ __ ]
black you look like [ __ ] blade in the
[ __ ] first scene so it's people
getting bit my neck blood everywhere
that's a [ __ ] special you know I'm
saying beside that that's it I got a
cool chick on Sade and I've watched the
baby until [ __ ] Park and from there I
go to a [ __ ] little chitchat before a
near beaten there from them that's right
again for the doctor's office and my
[ __ ] back and then we got a podcast
late o'clock tonight [ __ ]
so get ready to rock if you got it if
you don't have a briefing make the call
if you got an animal even if you got
heroin sharpen the [ __ ] needle cuz
we're going deep into the murky waters
of the underworld okay became the Gotham
again for sold-out shows I want to thank
you with all my [ __ ] heart so beside
that it's all about you [ __ ]
tremendous exhaling they're [ __ ]
garbage a but everything else makes me
your pain your [ __ ] agony is troubles
you just blow em out and go flop it I'm
putting a crown on today somebody's
sniffing my [ __ ] nutsack doctor
that's the attitude I'm on Monday
you don't want with two guns you've our
four yeah I'm saying you just come out
the box like [ __ ] anyone Monday time
to call these [ __ ] up its
envelope day [ __ ]
well luna compiler they're telling to
mama jalapeno here ayah or here Luna but
his Monday I can't [ __ ] around today but
is the strongest attitude you have you
don't give a [ __ ] today I don't give a
[ __ ] who's coming to town I'll give a
[ __ ] about your mother coming for dinner
I don't give a [ __ ] but you listen I
gotta get out there and stab them
[ __ ] you gotta set your mark and
enforce it today is the day you plan the
[ __ ] Flag in somebody's ass for who
remembers that we get the time to spend
together and get fired up together cuz
that's all this is this is get the [ __ ]
out of here this is the [ __ ] this is
the little soldier tell them the big
soldiers it's over [ __ ] you gotta
want then get what's yours you
understand me
stop [ __ ] around who gives a [ __ ]
about your iPhone look at me
just [ __ ] yeah black people getting shot
your next cop sucks
unless you do this in the morning just
slow it down you're smoking you plan out
your day and you keep your [ __ ] eyes
open I'm saying let's move we gotta take
this [ __ ] to the hope tonight
you John you this reef ain't [ __ ]
around this look at it again cuz I can't
see hardwire where's the [ __ ] they give
the [ __ ] terrorists up one time oh
baby before they shoot him with the good
stuff
and I said you gotta wonder what
Jennifer Aniston - all right now she's
spraying that [ __ ] monkey would shine
everything she's getting ready she's
bump into bread to bad breads at the
[ __ ] weed store you don't wanna hang
out with [ __ ] clean white chicks no
more he's ready good dick sucked by
animals don't that's the result okay and
that's it and that's that you're gonna
walk there they ain't gonna stop you
today now they [ __ ] were you telling
uncle Joey sent you number two eight
o'clock tonight the Church of what's
happening now number three Wednesday
night the Ice House $10 tickets you
can't beat those and running my special
and you guys are gonna help me okay
that's it that's it and that's that
grab your clock salute the flag eat some
oatmeal take a good [ __ ] and that's what
Monday's are all about I love you pops
up to see you tonight eight o'clock
be there or be square